nous allons parler de la recette du
hachis d'amour tout le monde sait faire
le hachis c'est très simple nous allons
commencer par une décoction dans un
chaudron de cuivre rouge quatre ans
d'orge de libye de pinte de lait
d'ânesse une poignée de rose sécher une
pincée de sel d'ammoniac et une cuillère
à soupe dans ce mâle ou femelle mal mal
c'est beaucoup plus léger alors nous
mettons à feu doux
nous laissons marcher tout doucement
nous recouvrons et nous ne nous occupons
plus de rien du tout du tout du tout m
pendant que va cuire la décoction dans
un mortier de marbre comme celui ci je
vais mettre un crapaud desséché acheter
un vendredi 13 à 13 euros 13 est passé à
la moulinette un samedi soir entre 20h
et 21h sur la première ou la deuxième
chaîne
ça n'a aucune importance pourvu que ce
soit bien voulu bien piles et je vais il
ajouté tout d'abord 3 oignons émincés
3,4 oeil de perdrix 4 oeil de perdrix le
ciel d'un caméléon le fiel d'un caméléon
que j'aurais fait sauter au prêt alors
un bouquet garni avec chiendent chicorée
à main et poudre d'antimoine et p un
verre d'uriné de lynx un verre à liqueur
à liqueur alors je vais tout pile et
ensemble bien comme il faut jusqu'à ce
que j'obtienne jusqu'à ce que j'obtienne
une pâte lisse un peu épaisses onctueuse
et à ce moment-là l'a dit
action la décoction aura réduit
suffisamment regardé santé c'est un
poison violent qui veut faire taire des
grenouilles toulan versera bouillon de
carême dans les marais les états
maintenant nous allons verser le contenu
du mortier dans le fondre et je vais
remuer avec beaucoup de précaution afin
qu'il n'y ait pas de grumeaux et
l'assaisonnement maintenant mais j'y
viens j'y viens vous êtes bien pressé ce
soir c'est que le roi se couche à 10
heures ça sera prêt
cotto au cuillère qui chaque année en
belgique
nous allons pour l'assaisonnement
m une pince une pincée de mire parfumée
nous allons ajouter 25 août de vitriol
25 août et deux hausses de cornes de
gazelle rap et je vais remuer tout ça
dans le chaudron
je vais couler dans un plat et puis je
decorvet selon mon goût ça n'a aucune
importance
et l'on peut à partir de maintenant
servir à la personne visée sinon petite
fille attention c'est chaud bonsoir
madame de montespan pour soir monsieur
devrait veiller mes amitiés à votre
femme
[Musique]